foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
so I got kind of curious with seeing all
these videos in my sub box over the past
couple months of people getting taken to
Chicago to test 5G and doing all these
crazy speed tests
um but then I started to notice they all
sort of have a couple things in common
but really it was just getting me
curious about the whole thing so I
bought a 5G phone and then I drove to
the nearest 5G City and I tried it for
myself so this is my new 1 600 Samsung
Galaxy S10 5G on Verizon and so the crew
and I drove from the studio to the
nearest 5G city which is Providence
Rhode Island so for those unfamiliar a
brief explainer what is 5G well we all
have 4G now 5G is the fifth generation
of wireless network technology and so
all the big carriers are working on
building out their 5G networks right now
Verizon at T Sprint we're all working on
5G the main theme of 5G is again speed
every new generation of the wireless
networks are significantly faster and
more capable than the previous some of
you may remember the old and very slow
2G and 3G and how much better 4G is than
those 5G represents another step forward
so to take advantage of 5G you need a 5G
device with 5G radios and a 5G Network
so for me that's the Galaxy S10 5G and
it's Verizon who's building up their 5G
Network in certain cities one location
at a time so you can't just get a
software update to a 4G phone to just
enable 5G that's right I'm talking to
you at T changing people's status bars
to say 5ge when it's really just 4G
it's stupid it's basically a lie you're
kind of trying to trick people into
thinking they got 5G 5ge is not 5G
it's still 4G
it's really a shame
anyway 5G is built on what's called
millimeter waves it's a new section of
very high frequency spectrum upwards of
20 gigahertz all the way to near 96
gigahertz but the catch is the higher
the frequency of any wave the lesser the
range like that's just the truth on
paper so for the same reason 5 gigahertz
Wi-Fi doesn't travel as far as 2.4
gigahertz Wi-Fi the same reason
microwaves don't cook things on the
other side of the glass wall
that's the same reason 5G doesn't travel
as well through the real world so
millimeter waves biggest problem is that
even if you're standing pretty close to
the node like a couple hundred feet away
it only really travels well within
direct line of sight so things like
trees and walls and buildings block and
disrupt The High Frequency signal even
if you're still close to it I've heard
even that rain in the air could
potentially be a problem so this is why
I wanted to test this for myself so we
drove to Providence Rhode Island which
is on the growing list of Verizon's 5G
cities it's not the whole city that's
one big 5G hotbed it's only certain
areas sort of tucked away happens to be
near Brown University where we found one
of them and we found it by finding one
of these this is a 5G node or three
nodes to be specific at the top of a
light pole you could tell because it
said Verizon right on the pole and
because if you stand right next to it
with a 5G phone in your hand and run a
speed test the results are just
absolutely ridiculous the 4G and the
notification bar switches to indicate 5G
and you open up your app of choice and
run a speed test and I'm seeing easy 700
800 900 often well above a thousand
megabits per second download highest
result I actually saw in my personal
testing was 1.9 gigabits per second
briefly from fast.com that's just that's
that's just hilariously fast like you
could almost use your whole data cap in
a minute
um dream like speeds very very nice of
course you want to see what this type of
speed is actually good for other than a
speed test so YouTube videos just played
instantly without any buffering in HD I
could fast forward right off the bat no
problem web browsing of course would be
super fast hopping into the Play Store
to download a gigantic game like pubg
mobile progress moves pretty fast not
like a blink of an eye and it's done but
still miles better than it would be on
LTE the fortnite downloader progressed
faster than the fortnite installer would
have meaning it's it's crazy impressive
and downloading an entire Stranger
Things episode from Netflix in HD on
this phone took about four seconds so
you could grab a whole season in
probably like 30 seconds if you wanted
to which is again absolutely ideal but
again here's the thing this is all while
standing like right next to the Tower
with a direct line of sight you know
perfectly ideal conditions great weather
once I left that it kind of broke down
pretty quickly so right around the
corner of this brick building just to
get into the shade so literally maybe 75
feet away from the node but behind a
wall I'm getting much slower 5G it's
still 5G but you can see the numbers
here now I mean it's kind of crazy to
call 200 300 400 down slow but compared
to what I was getting before that's a
pretty big difference to basically cut
your speed in half just by walking a
couple meters down the block
and also notice just by walking halfway
down the block I'd start bouncing back
and forth between 4G and 5G and like it
was frustratingly inconsistent even when
I did have a line of sight with maybe a
tree or two sort of nearby my phone
would drop 5G and then jump back on
again and you can see it in the
notification bar it would drop back to
5G and then back to 4G and then when I
was on 5G and I ran the speed test it
would be great I get a thousand down
again which is awesome but when I ran it
at 4G I would get 4G speeds and it's
really good 4G speeds but it was just
weird getting those results back to back
like half a block away and when I waited
a minute I'd suddenly get 5G again and
get a thousand down so what's the
solution for this well as we understand
it basically just putting a lot of nodes
all over the place so essentially to
maximize coverage and improve technology
so that when you move behind one
obstacle or sort of drive through a city
you actively switch between nodes that
you can connected to kind of like we do
now with 4G towers but just much faster
and I think that's the part that kind of
scares people it seems Seems like a
Brute Force way to actually go about
fixing the problem but that's the
current plan is to just blanket areas
with these lower powered cells that let
you switch between them very very
quickly instead of one giant 4G Tower
like you have now my gut feeling is that
an infrastructure where you cover an
entire city and eventually an entire
country in these little nodes is going
to be incredibly expensive and probably
take a very long time like years so it's
a long way off but here's another thing
to notice
even with me standing right next to a 5G
node and holding a brand new 2019 5G
phone
there were still some drawbacks to
notice the main three are heat battery
and upload so for one the upload appears
to still be happening at 4G speed even
when I'm connected to 5G I never broke
100 megabits per second up in all my
testing which is still a great speed but
my dream of uploading an 8K YouTube
video in like five seconds or going live
streaming high resolution VR or
something like that are not possible at
all yet now you've probably also noticed
the Ping is still at 4G levels too the
goal is to get this down to a
millisecond or less but that isn't
happening yet in these tests either and
then heat and Battery are something that
this phone seemed to specifically suffer
from when I was testing I started my day
when we got to Providence with 75
Battery did all my testing and that
maybe took about four or five hours and
when we finished I was at 21 battery and
the phone was warm to the touch the
whole time this is why you see 5G
versions of phones coming out almost
always have a larger battery than their
normal 4G Brothers including the Galaxy
S10 5G and the phone getting warm during
the testing too when I wasn't even
gaming or doing anything graphically
intensive just watching some YouTube
videos and download tests was a little
concerning so the bottom line 5G is like
folding phones right now in 2019 clearly
not ready yet
but when you use it and you get just the
right use case and you're at just the
right space you get this amazing little
glimpse into the future that you wish
was ready for right now because it's so
great but it's not and currently the
cons sort of outweigh the pros and I
wouldn't spend extra money on it right
now in 2019. the future of 5G is really
bright assuming you know the
infrastructure happens and isn't too
obtrusive and that's a big assumption
but then we're talking virtual reality
streaming and networks of autonomous
cars that are all internet connected and
talking to each other and maybe even
think about remote surgery with a 5G
connected robot in one country with a
doctor over here and a patient in
another country and everything just
working seamlessly like all this super
high bandwidth low latency stuff maybe
the end of video buffering altogether
all seem possible but as of right now in
2019
it just isn't ready yet but I'm super
ready for when it is either way thanks
for watching catch you guys in the next
one peace
big thanks to nordvpn for sponsoring
this video so what is a VPN a virtual
private Network secures your internet
traffic encrypts it and routes it
through a remote server while changing
your original IP address so essentially
it protects your data from anyone trying
to Snoop on it privacy is one of the
biggest concerns online and with how
much I travel especially lately and how
much I use public Wi-Fi and hotel Wi-Fi
a VPN feels like a no-brainer so nordvpn
for sponsoring is offering 75 off plus
one additional month free for using the
code mkvpn so if you're even a tiny bit
worried about your online security and
privacy take the first step and check
out nordvpn
thanks for watching catch you later